blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an entire
non-fiction book in just 15 minutes you
can try it for free and get 25 off a
subscription by going to blinkist.com
pakman welcome everybody i i have to
start with some really crazy things
today um the first thing is the next
kind of chapter in the
um
martyrdom and lionization of kyle
rittenhouse now i'm not going to retell
you the entire kyle rittenhouse story
but kyle rittenhouse was 17 years old
when he went to kenosha wisconsin
with a firearm and he killed two people
shot a third claimed self-defense and
was acquitted found not guilty uh as i
said that based on how these laws are
written
that not guilty verdict is is not really
the issue here it's uh
kyle's presence there being emblematic
of so many of the things wrong with the
country
uh gun culture education parenting etc
and one of the
cons concerns we knew what was going to
happen was that kyle rittenhouse was
going to be made a hero he got
an interview with tucker carlson with a
hero's welcome he got to meet trump etc
this is now taking on an even more
insane tone
there is a new series about kyle
rittenhouse produced with tucker carlson
hosting and narrating it's on fox nation
fox nation is a fox news kind of like
offshoot
that
includes rehabilitating the program cops
so it kind of gives you a sense of the
type of content that they produce and
it's like a bizarre
uh
reality show
made to
make him look like a complete and total
hero so check out just like a little
clip of this and just the entire vibe
it's all completely insane look at this
kyle written house oh kyle rittenhouse
it's so nice to meet you it's really
good to meet you i can't believe you're
here
well
we're fans of yours as you know yeah
yep that's me you're probably wondering
how i ended up in this situation
for most americans kyle rittenhouse is
more meme than man
but in real life rittenhouse is a
working-class kid from the least
privileged sector of our society so
yeah
as i've said first of all who's the
audience for this right that's one thing
to think about like we're watching it as
a goof
and because it's so absurd
um and because it's a media story that
there is a media outlet doing this but
there are people who watch this
seriously and they go wow what a
what a hero what a great kid he did a
great thing and remember he didn't do a
great thing
he was somewhere he shouldn't have been
with a gun he shouldn't have had
uh and um
he caused a situation in which he feared
for his life i i even would concede he
plausibly feared for his life and he was
acquitted but we don't celebrate it we
say wow this was a tragedy it should
have been avoided altogether the lesson
wouldn't be he's a hero the lesson would
be would have made sense never to go in
the first place but this show makes him
a hero
then and this is just
wacky
tucker carlson in a direct-to-camera
sort of thing
explains
that
um
what we have he he basically uses kind
of like bolshevik style revolution as an
analogy
to the desire for the imposition of
anarcho-tyranny in the united states and
links all of this back to kyle
rittenhouse take a look at this
tyranny you may have heard the term
here's the most straightforward
definition it means
anarchy for the people in charge tyranny
for the population
tyranny is a system in which pedophiles
and career criminals are released from
prison by the state to terrorize the law
abiding
the law-abiding defend themselves
they're prosecuted by the state for
murder smeared by the media as
terrorists arguably a domestic terrorist
all as corporate sponsored activist
groups burn their country to the ground
we're seeing this but we've seen it
before in the years before the bolshevik
revolution russia was deeply
destabilized by crime and chaos
and that set the stage for the bolshevik
takeover in the soviet union during the
great terror political dissidents were
put on trial for daring to defend
themselves against criminals in the
soviet union you could only use a knife
in self-defense after you'd been stabbed
does that sound familiar the trial of
kyle rittenhouse may be the first
anarcho-tyrannical show trial in the
united states it may not be the last so
the most curious part about that is the
analysis
is a completely bogus analysis it's
flaccid in every in every way it's
pathetic it's a wet noodle
but do you think the audience of this
network and of this show that's watching
it in a serious way
knows about bolshevism or
anarcho-tyranny i mean seriously like
even it this is a perfect example of you
know people
you ask them do you read history they go
yeah i read bill o'reilly's history
books like okay
who is the audience here
and it's all wacky and it's meant
specifically to inspire a certain type
of person
to accept without questioning what
tucker is telling you and of course
accept that kyle rittenhouse is a hero
truly just bizarre stuff
um here's a clip from the end
and in this scene
they put kyle rittenhouse like it's so
overproduced they have kyle rittenhouse
wearing a suit on a beach
and tucker celebrates that
kyle rittenhouse is moving to florida
which is a free state and also frames
written house as a victim who now is
going to have to deal with all this for
the rest of his life how rittenhouse
wanted to move to the paradise of
florida to the free state now he has his
chance even so he will never have the
luxury of living a normal life he'll
never be able to erase the slander and
stigma laid on him by the media and by
his prosecution
those are the consequences of the trial
of kyle
the next time it could be you
i i like how tucker says you could be
next you know one way to avoid being the
next kyle written house is don't go to
locations of unrest with firearms then
you're not going to be the next kyle
written house now of course tucker would
say well no there's a million other ways
in which you could be victimized by the
system the way he was but what an
overproduced sham
and my prediction is that this show will
do really well with the fox nation
audience so this is we we said they
would make him a hero
they're making him a hero they're making
him a martyr they're making him a sage
and it is completely and totally
disgusting but we knew it would happen
um we've talked for a while now about
how the republican party has essentially
abandoned policy like in some vague way
taxes are bad and you know regulation is
bad but even since early in the trump
administration after the tax bill passed
the republican party stopped being about
policy but rather about cultural issues
i am going to show you now a fundraising
email sent out by donald trump save
america pack which has the closest thing
to a policy platform on it trump lists a
bunch of stuff
almost like we would list well we want
to make sure everybody has access to
health care we want to make sure that um
you're not going to be killed by
pollution and that emitters of pollution
are regulated and we want to make sure
that people are paying uh the right
amount of taxes to properly fund social
services and hear the social policy
right
trump sends out a fundraising email that
looks like a policy list but it's crazy
look at this trump you know trump's not
writing this but it's being sent down to
under trump's name
friend have you noticed that the radical
left is now admitting i was right about
everything they lied about before the
election
and here's the list
hydroxychloroquine
works now
hydroxychloroquine is a medication that
works for some things no evidence it
works for covid
the china virus came from a chinese lab
that's not been demonstrated
hunter biden's laptop was real
well
it was a real laptop
or it was really hunters or it really
contained the things you claim again
this this is the like it's like a policy
platform of crazy lafayette square was
not cleared for a photo op in fact we
know that it was
the russian bounty stories was fake it
appears to have been real
we did produce vaccines before the end
of 2020 in record time okay i mean
you know that's one where it's sort of
what is being implied
the mrna platform allows rapid vaccine
production so when trump says without me
it would have taken 10 or 12 years no
without mrna it might have taken seven
to seven or eight years you had nothing
to do with mrna and that's why the
vaccine was produced quickly but blue
state lockdowns didn't work uh you know
what's interesting about that is they
sort of did actually like early we had
the situation where the coveted cases
and deaths were disproportionately
happening in blue urban centers because
those were the places with the major
airports flying back and forth to china
and europe where the virus was brought
to the united states from
once vaccines became widely available
the case rate and the death rates in red
states and in particular in trump
counties
way way way higher than in biden county
so that's wrong too
schools should be reopened
they basically are open uh because of
omicron now a few colleges have said
we're going back to remote but basically
schools are open critical race theory is
a disaster for our schools and our
country and our southern border security
program was unprecedentedly successful
this is so funny because it's sort of
like a stupid person's policy platform
it looks like policy there's really no
policy like
hydroxychloroquine works it's a
statement of fact
it happens to be incomplete it works but
not for covid
but what's the policy behind it and this
seems to be to some degree a reaction to
realizing that we've got to have
something we're kind of running on to
get people to give us money
but we're going to make it really what
is at the end of the day cultural stuff
and the saddest thing about it is
the glenn
victory in virginia
shows us that this type of thing works
he ran against critical race theory in
virginia which was not even being taught
in virginia schools and he won terry
mcauliffe made mistakes as well so this
may be
the closest we get to a platform from
republicans it's a joke but sadly it
might work
and that's why we've got to really be
ready for 2022. part of getting ready is
we are going to try to resuscitate
declining membership numbers on january
1st we'll be doing a one-day membership
special it's going to be huge and if
you'd like to be notified just get on
our mailing list by signing up at
davidpakman.com january 1st you'll get a
beautiful email from me telling you
exactly how to sign up let's take a
quick break and we'll be right back
after this
one of our sponsors is blinkist who's
been supporting the david pakman show
longer than any other sponsor blinkist
is the app that lets you listen to or
read an entire non-fiction book in just
15 minutes blinkist is the way to absorb
those books you can't make time for
blinkist takes top non-fiction titles
pulls out the book's key takeaways and
insights and gives it to you in the form
of a text or audio explainer that you
can consume in 15 minutes with blinkist
now you actually do have time to learn
about all the things you've been wanting
to tackle on the blinkist app i just
listened to this is your mind on plants
by the great michael pollan
super interesting the history of
caffeine and so many other things
blinkist has you covered on podcasts too
blinkist takes long episodes of popular
podcasts and distills them into audio
you can listen to in 15 minutes with
blinkist you can become knowledgeable
about so many different things you can
have conversations with people about
more topics blinkist makes you more
well-rounded try blinkist for free and
get 25 off a subscription go to
blinkist.com
david pakman the link is down below
the program that you are listening to
right now or watching right now the
david pakman show is primarily funded by
viewers and listeners who sign up on my
website and get a yearly or monthly
membership these memberships come with
very powerful benefits including a daily
extra show
as well as access to commercial free
audio and video streams of the shows and
so many other great things
sign up at joinpacman.com
we are going to hear from some folks in
the audience we take calls now via
discord at davidpakman.com
discord it's great to hear
what is on people's minds why don't we
start today
with chris
from texas chris from texas what's going
on
hey david this is chris from texas how
are you doing i mean never mind about
that i'm doing well thank you
i guess one thing i'm wondering is that
like with biden
i'm
i know some people are wanting bernie to
run again but i don't agree with that
because of the fact that like
i love bernie with all my heart but i
feel that with bernie
after losing twice i think it's just
gonna make him look bad and i think
it'll hurt the progressive movement
overall for him to run again just
because
it'll make us look as if we
are not willing to cooperate with the
democrats i don't think it's about
cooperation at all but i agree with you
i think that as a combination of uh
bernie's failed runs so far as well as
bernie's age
um i i some people might be furious with
me but i think the window of opportunity
for bernie has closed uh first and
foremost
if joe biden runs again bernie's not
going to beat him in a primary so that
already makes us look at 2028
and yeah i just i i just don't see it i
think it's unrealistic if somebody wants
to change my mind you can try but i just
don't see it
yeah i guess i'm guessing i'm just also
worried also about the future as well
like uh with biden's approval ratings
going down i kind of want him to do
other things like
maybe do another ubi
and potentially
also and potentially also doing
something like along the lines of like
maybe
being more forgiving on the student loan
debt because wait a second hold on dude
when you say do another ubi do you mean
a coveted stimulus check
i mean that's probably on my least
worries but i feel like i'd be more
willing for him to do something along
the lines of like
maybe extending student loan for
forgiveness or
maybe
giving student maybe at least
four cancelling off at least ten
thousand dollars of student loan debt
yeah i have to tell you i i agree with
those things i i want him to do those
things i never believed that those were
things joe biden was going to do when he
was running and he seems to have no
interest in doing them i i just don't
think he's going to do them now should
we should we pressure of course i mean
this is what activism is for but i don't
think he ever had any interest in doing
those things but i think the point we're
maybe
kind of converging on is
the left needs some kind of uh the
progressive left needs a charismatic
leader
uh within the democratic party
i don't think it's bernie is it aoc i
don't know i think it's too early to say
but i do think that a charismatic leader
is needed in the progressive left
i do feel like aoc would be a good
candidate but i feel like one problem
that she has is that she's only been her
highest level of stake of being elected
is only the house of representatives i
feel like she would either need to at
least
maybe challenge someone like what's her
name again gillibrand or
or or hawkel for a state level position
okay that's fair yeah i mean that there
will be time to look at that but it
sounds like you and i are mostly on the
same page
one last question i have though too
i guess considering i'm kind of a little
scared about the republicans potentially
getting back to the senate and said it
in in-house in 2022 yeah why isn't joe
biden or any of the democrats with their
their power right now try to admit dc in
puerto rico estates and so we can at
least give us some way of a buffer from
preventing the republicans from gaining
more seats again i love the idea joe
biden doesn't just doesn't seem
interested it just doesn't seem a
priority now remember you know dc would
almost certainly
be two democratic senators puerto rico
is a little bit more of a question mark
puerto rico is more conservative than
some people think on balance it would
still be great for the democratic party
but biden just doesn't seem interested
in that
yeah but we would get at least around
seven seats in the both in the in
congress at least that sounds about
right yeah that sounds about right i
would love to see it i think they should
be states i don't believe it will happen
before 2024.
okay all right thank you for the call
david all right my pleasure thank you
again thanks chris appreciate hearing
from you uh good question specific good
questions let's go next to jason from
huntsville alabama what's happening in
alabama these days
i still don't understand how anyone's
sorry
jason from alabama you're on the air and
it sounds like you're on another call
there
listening to some kind of show
jason did you want to talk to me or are
you just watching tv i don't know
all right well that's too bad uh let's
go next to nick from long island nick
from long island you are on the air um
so
i wanted to ask you since democrats
aren't really caring about getting
anything done right now like lowering
prescription drug prices because of the
roadblocks
that we face in the senate um
and
the fact that biden can can try to use
pressure politics do you think democrats
actually care about winning in 2022
since like they're not like getting
anything done
so i don't know that i would
characterize the situation the way
you're characterizing it i mean to speak
specifically about prescription drugs
buildback better actually has a bunch of
prescription drug stuff in it including
limiting out-of-pocket insulin costs
through insurance to
a month which is major just in and of
itself given the number of people with
diabetes in the united states
i agree with you generally speaking that
the democrats are not getting enough
done and there needs to be some other
major policy accomplishment to be able
to point to in order to justify people
voting for democrats in 2022 and on
whether democrats care about winning in
2022 i do think there are some democrats
who have been given the numbers and
they've been shown here's what's going
on with redistricting here's what's
going on this
we're gonna lose the house in 2022 and
some may have given up i don't and i
disagree with that position
um but i don't know that it's that they
don't care i i just i think i just see
the all of the situation a little bit
differently than you
yeah well you know another big issue
that i hear a lot on like shows like tyt
um they talk about how
you know
they say legalized bribery has something
to do with
not getting popular uh provisions done
and it just seems to me like like
corporations really want democrats to
lose elections because republicans would
it would make sense because republicans
would easily just grant them more tax
cuts don't you think so not no it's not
as cut and dry there are lots of large
corporations that understand that the
economic policies of democrats are more
demand-side stimulus rather than
trickle-down supply-side stuff and they
know that those things are good for them
many corporations realize if everybody
makes a little more money we now have we
now have customers with a little bit
more money which they can spend here
like that's a demand side stimulus
economic idea and the truth is for most
of most corporations they're not really
most corporations are not political in
the sense of the corporation is liberal
or conservative they're trying to do
what's best for them and often it's
hedging their bets by donating to both
sides i mean that's the sick reality of
it you look at cable uh isps and cable
companies you look at uh you know big
food most of these companies are
donating some to both sides so that they
can have friends in power no matter who
wins
yeah i think uh that pretty much answers
my my questions
all right nick from long island thanks
very much uh appreciate the call
let's go next to cody from san diego
cody i'm gonna be in san diego this
weekend in fact how's the weather
looking
david can you hear me i can hear you
cody
uh it's it's uh just got done raining
down here but it's it's looking pretty
good today all right good well yeah i'm
hoping to have a nice uh nice sunny
weekend
yeah um my question was
uh first one
i was just uh
i keep hearing like all these
people on the
i guess i mean obviously on the right
but
a lot of people on the left have like
a problem with aoc and
her
policies and just i guess her
personality and everything i was just
wondering what your opinion was and
uh
what what you feel about her what you
what you think about her i i generally
tend to agree with her and like a lot of
what she does so yeah i think um i think
aoc is extremely skilled politically in
terms of her ability to communicate in
terms of her ability to participate in
congressional hearings and and question
people i think she gets a lot of issues
right as i've said before i think she
lacks some
knowledge when it comes to certain
economic ideas and on some foreign
policy stuff but she's still relatively
new
we would expect anybody to lack
knowledge in some areas it's not like a
big deal you know it's not like a big
attack on aoc
um so i think she has major potential to
be a huge player for decades in the
progressive movement if she wants to and
at the same time she may not want to she
may want to do this for a little bit and
then do something something completely
different so i think in terms of
thinking about the future of the
progressive movement we don't want to
put all our eggs in any one basket if
that makes sense
yeah it does
um just a real i guess my my other
question would be
uh i heard a lot
uh i get it was in the past there was an
article that came out
and destiny talked about it a little bit
uh that
people were talking about
how
how much voter suppression actually
affects elections so
i
um i recognize that like it's probably
kind of a
combination of
like voter suppression and
uh redistricting tactics that kind of
cumulative
affect elections but in your opinion uh
realistically how much
how much do you think like voter
suppression tactics actually
this is such a hard thing to answer
because the first thing is which
elections right which elections are we
talking about a presidential race are we
talking about congressional districts
for the house of representatives i'm not
actually i'm not asking you to give me
the answers i'm just saying in order to
really answer the question we first need
to define that
then
there are aspects of this that can be
measured and aspects that are tougher to
measure so for example
if someone
is rejected from voting because of a
specific rule we could say wow that's
definitely someone whose vote was
affected by voter suppression but if
there are people who because of their
awareness of
voting has been limited in this way or
voting places or whatever the case may
be
say i'm not even going to look at voting
this year that's sort of like soft voter
suppression and i don't really i don't
trust that we can accurately quantify
that in any real way so my answer is
in in some total
there is no doubt that voter suppression
tactics combined with gerrymandering
have an effect how many races are won or
lost on that basis it's a very difficult
question to answer but here's a really
important thing
the fact that it's a difficult question
to answer doesn't mean that we should
fall for well then it must be having no
effect that would be fallacious to go to
that
yeah i tend to agree well that's the
questions i had thank you so much for
answering thank you for calling oh great
to great to hear from you
why don't we go next to uh terry from
fresno terry you are on the air
hey david how's it going it's going well
thank you
so i wanted to ask about uh the idea of
optics in intra-political issues because
it seems like optics don't really matter
across like party lines but insofar as
like um like
democrat on democrat like what's the
purpose of arguing optics and something
when that's clearly not what's happening
i don't know what you mean so give me
give me an example of an argument
democrats have with each other about
optics what's an example
like the optics of aoc going to uh the
met gala wearing a dress that says taxa
rich okay like
there have been arguments about like oh
it's not a good look for somebody who
is uh
fighting for
uh
income inequality
who um
is going to like the met gala where a
bunch of rich people are oh i see and
then there was the counterpoint which
was like no it's great that she was
there because she was a dif she she was
something different instead of just
celebrities and whatever and that's
exactly where like that that debate
you're talking about
yeah things of that nature because like
ultimately i think it obscures like
actual issues i i tend to agree with you
i tend to agree with you so for me that
debate was not interesting for me the
optics debate that's more interesting is
actually one that's between republicans
and democrats and i'll give you an
example and tell me if you think this is
more more relevant and interesting
we've talked about hypocrisy in politics
before and we've talked about how
uh you know take take foreign policy
first republicans said it's patriotic to
go to war when it was the iraq war and
then with obama obama was unpatriotic
because he wasn't willing to start wars
and he was going to leave the country
open to attacks but then when it was
donald trump the patriotic thing again
was he won't get us into wars but
hillary will and then now with joe biden
it's why is joe biden giving russia
warnings so they're totally hypocritical
right the the problem is the right
doesn't care about their own hypocrisy
whether while the left does seem to care
about hypocrisy that's really
interesting to me because it raises
questions of
should the left also stop caring about
hypocrisy and double standards or how do
you
take advantage of the hypocrisy of the
right if their voters don't care about
the hypocrisy for me that's like an
optics debate that's much more relevant
and substantive
yeah i and i can understand that
although i would say from my perspective
um
you can't win a basketball game if your
opponents have guns and are shooting
people sure you know what i mean like
you have to play the same game that
everybody else is playing so like to me
uh the optics conversation insofar as
like they don't care about hypocrisy but
we do that conversation it just stops
because like if you're not willing to
play the same game then you're already
losing you know what i mean i agree and
this gets to a lot of our discussions
about
without committing crimes or doing
straight-up immoral things democrats
have to recognize that we have to use
the system we have to try to win or
otherwise the system will just get worse
yeah and i to some degree i don't think
um i i'm not wholly against and granted
i'm very much so on the political
extreme like i i am for a long time i
was like one of those people who was all
about the spirit of the game right like
you've you played basketball right yeah
so when you go play basketball you
respect the foul if somebody calls a
foul you're playing a pickup game you
just respect the call sure don't argue
it you don't do all that but like if
you're playing against people who argue
calls and will just shave points off and
do all sorts of stuff then what's the
point in playing the game if you're not
gonna do the same thing right i guess
the question is yes yes exactly unless
the the problem becomes when things are
more life or death than basketball and
you end up with really bad options of
having to degrade yourself maybe or just
let them be the only players which is
also terrible that's you got you got
some tough decisions to make
you absolutely degrade yourself in every
instance are you kidding me yes if the
choice is like letting a bunch of your
constituents maybe lose the right to
have uh abortions and like maybe playing
a little bit unfair or doing the same
things that republicans do then i feel
like the option every time is do what's
best for your constituents right right
right right
all right very important issues i
apprecia appreciate you bringing them to
me today thank you all right let's take
a very quick break we are going to keep
taking calls right after this short
break so if you are holding don't hang
up we're going right back to the phones
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back
a really long time and plenty of other
awesome membership perks go to
joinpackman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount joinpakman.com
all right let's go back to the phone
lines and hear from a few more people we
don't really use the phone lines anymore
we use discord which you can find at
davidpakman.com
discord that is the place
to find it and chat with me
let's go to
uh tyler from columbia is that columbia
south carolina
tyler from columbia on the air hey david
sorry it's uh tyler from columbus ohio
oh columbus ohio got it you're on the
air
well thanks for having me i'm a long
time listener a big fan of the show
thank you
i guess my first question is um
i don't really think
given the polling trajectory with you
know kamal harris and joe biden
i think we would almost assuredly lose
if we run either of them in 2024
uh i think brian's gonna be too old to
run i don't think he's gonna seek
re-election and i think you know kamala
harris is not a good choice
uh so who do you think if we're up to
you who would you pick to be the
democratic nominee in 2024 i you know i
have no answer because at this point
there is really nobody in the democratic
party that i'm genuinely excited about
and that i see and when i say excited i
mean not only do i like them on policy
but that i also
believe that they are sort of like a
political superstar of sorts uh you know
there was something like him or hate him
there was something about bill clinton
when he entered the national scene where
it was like this guy is a political
superstar
uh different than you agree with him on
every policy or anything like that but
it was just he had a certain something
barack obama has a certain something i
don't think joe biden really has it but
i think the circumstances still allowed
him to win and i am with you i i think
that
particularly if trump is the nominee but
even if it's someone like ron desantis
who seems right you know we
looking now seems like the other
possible guy
um i don't know that biden wins
re-election and i think if he steps back
and uh there's sort of a coronation for
kamala harris and she's kind of just
handed the nomination i don't think she
beats trump or desantis so i am
extremely concerned what i'm trying to
do though is
say let's get through the midterms first
because what happens in the midterms is
going to really
determine the context in which 2024
takes place but i am as worried as you
are right now
do you think there is a scenario in
which democrats hold the house
i think it's possible but unlikely i
think we have to fight for it right i
don't know what what number i would
attach to it i would maybe call it 10 or
15 percent but that's high the stakes
are so big that you've got to fight if
you've got a 10 shot you got to fight
for that
i agree
thanks all right thank you so much for
the call very much appreciate it yeah i
don't want i'm not trying to be
unnecessarily pessimistic i'm just kind
of explaining it explaining it the way i
see it you know
let's go next to next to jeff from
dallas texas jeff you're on the air
wow literally sounds like water
near me you're not actually underwater
are you
no i was running oh my god okay what's
going on
oh sorry i was trying to get away okay
um yes so uh first off the show it's my
first time calling in so i'm just very
excited to be able to chat with you
thank you so i'm sorry i'm gonna sound a
little nervous because i've never done
this before no you're doing great
okay so um i kind of went
you know there's been a lot of talk
about
um the
all right unfortunately jeff your
service is so bad we can't hear you
you're going in and out so we will have
to try to make the connection at some
point in the future let's go next to
noah from new jersey noah you were on
the air
noah from new jersey you're on the air
hey can you hear me david yes i can
cool um so
i don't know if this is a good question
to ask it's not maybe as informational
i kind of have a two-part question i
guess um
so
um
i live in a i still live at home with my
parents and they're both republicans
um my dad has the vaccine
uh is considering
not getting the uh the booster shot i
just got my booster shot okay um and my
mom is completely closed off to the idea
of getting the vaccine so i just wanted
to see if you had any insight uh on sort
of how to deal with sort of family
interactions uh when that's sort of the
dynamic well why doesn't she want the
vaccine
she's
she's not quite on the level of q anon
but she's kind of uh
you know a little bit paranoid and uh
definitely has some mis misinformation
misleading her
okay like what does she believe about it
i honestly to be honest i don't even
really know i know she doesn't really
believe that there's like i don't think
she believes the whole tracking device
thing but i think
that um
she just doesn't think it works maybe
she doesn't think that's necessary uh
yesterday she said that my niece
has a cold and i said is it definitely a
cold or is it covet and she said
well it's definitely a cult because kids
get colds all the time and i was like
well
yeah it's not really an argument so
here's the thing right first you've got
to figure out what it actually is
because you said a few different things
you said you don't think she believes
the tracking chip stuff she may not
believe the vaccine works or she may not
believe that the vaccine is necessary
these are all different things so my
process would be and obviously you have
to decide for yourself how much you want
to argue about this with your mom but my
process would be first
really figure out by listening
why they don't want the vaccine only
when you understand that can we even go
to the next step the next step would be
figure out what would change their mind
so if they say well the reason i don't
want it is i don't think it's safe you
would say well
if your personal doctor told you it was
safe would you take it yeah i trust my
personal doctor great try to get her to
talk to her personal doctor other people
might say well i don't believe that it's
effective then you say well if i showed
you what
if who said it was effective would you
change your mind and maybe she says well
i don't know if if if you showed me data
or whatever the point here is first
you've really got to understand why she
doesn't want it right now it doesn't
seem like you understand that well
enough to really move on to step two
right
okay and uh and do i have time to ask
one other quick question yeah go ahead
go ahead so i i you know i've spent time
following people that maybe you know
used to be in my life that are
hardcore republicans simply for the the
fact of uh
sort of entertainment stuff that they
would post would be entertaining to me
sure um so i was i ended up unfollowing
most of those people because i just felt
like it was actually ended up being
draining to myself um and i didn't think
it was healthy so i just wanted uh kind
of wondered if you feel that being so uh
involved in politics and having to keep
yourself uh updated with it so much if
that sort of drains you mentally yeah
and and so oh i have to do this for work
so on my facebook i have unfollowed um
certain people like that i went to high
school with that completely lost their
minds like there's this one one woman
who i went to high school with graduated
with me at the st i knew she was sort of
a republican and before the pandemic she
would post some gun stuff and some
religious stuff
at the pandemic she started posting
every insane link to every conspiracy
theory vaccine stuff fauci bill gates
microchips everything everything
everything so i just unfollowed you know
because it's just it's just overload if
i'm just browsing facebook and keeping
up with what my friends are doing
i just i just don't need to be seeing
that i i do think the considerations
different like i work in this field so
like when i'm looking at twitter which i
use for work i can't just get rid of all
of the crazy right-wing stuff because
i'm reporting on it i'm covering it i'm
engaging with it but yeah it is draining
and another thing i recommend is
take days off entire days off i don't
follow what's going on on the weekends
barely at all like i'll see my mom on a
sunday morning and she'll be like did
you see and i'll be like i didn't see it
i checked out after finishing the friday
show so i think scheduled time away from
it is really
right all right thanks david thanks for
taking my call all right my pleasure uh
very good questions there i like it we
had a couple dropped calls today but the
ones that we got
were
really really good
um why don't we go next to uh let's try
marcus from manitoba canada marcus
you're on the air
hi david
hi please make sure that your discord
doesn't bling we've already heard one
bling and it's very distracting to
everybody
uh how do i turn off the blings i'm
sorry you gotta turn off your
notifications in your settings just turn
all sound notifications off but you can
go right into your question
uh okay
i i've been
i've been waiting for a long time to do
this uh i've been passed over every time
but
anyways going straight into the question
uh
uh my
uh
something that's something that i've
noticed uh sort of concerning
development that's really sort of been
taking place i guess you could say
across the democratic world but
uh
i think especially notably in america
is this
i think this growing tendency to view
democracy well there's this growing
cynicism about democracy
this
uh this kind of
view of democracy as a sort of purely
instrumental
uh
device right for
the
uh
simply sort of a means to the end of
uh
of enacting whatever policies whatever
ideology
uh
a particular side wants
uh to enact
and
uh
i think this is a very dangerous
development i don't know about you but i
i was wondering like what what what is
your view of of of democracy do you
think that democracy is something that
is inherently valuable
that that is some something to be uh
valued in itself whether or not
uh
your side is the one that is benefited
by it
or right you think that it is something
that is sort of of merely instrumental
value that it's only valuable if it
enacts policies that we
uh that we like that
i gotcha i don't have either view my
view is so my view is not that democracy
is valuable
regardless of the outcomes or regardless
of
in other i i don't believe that
democracy is valuable for its own sake
only
and i don't think that democracy is
valuable only as an instrument that
allows my side to win i think that
there's an in-between view which is we
can have a number of different systems
and there could be a system that is a
good system even if my side doesn't
always win
and that's generally speaking my view on
democracy i don't think democracy is
valuable for its own sake i think that
democracy has a lot of problems you go
to
you know uh right read socrates on
democracy and you know a lot of fair
criticisms of democracy and we talk
about many of them a lot of incompetent
people get to participate just like
others who are informed outcomes are
sometimes bad it can be a system can be
corrupted etc um so i don't think it's
valuable for its own sake at the same
time even when my side loses it doesn't
make me think we need a dictatorship or
we need authoritarianism or whatever i
do think that on its merits it's the
best system we've come up with so far
but that doesn't mean it's the only good
system i'm open to another system being
better so it's i have an in-between view
on that issue
okay
i mean i think that's a very reasonable
perspective
uh
it's something that i've noticed among
like obviously it's very blatant on on
right
uh both in the u.s and in in various
other countries that like you know
they're not even really pretending to
care about democracy anymore or they're
they're pretending but in just such a
transparently
uh cynical way yes absolutely if
hello
okay all right i guess he's gone uh good
question interesting topic that's gonna
do it for calls today we'll talk to
everybody again very soon sorry i wasn't
able to hear from everybody today
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com david pakman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos the daily bonus show
the commercial free daily show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month
check it out at patreon.com david pakman
show all right let's get into emails for
the week remember you can email info at
davidpakman.com if you have something to
say please use the email address
sparingly because uh if you use it a lot
your emails will get auto flagged into
the trash unfortunately i was actually
we were updating our system uh the other
day
and um we actually have close to a
hundred different people that email us
so much that their emails are just being
auto filtered so don't be one of those
folks send an occasional message if you
have something to say first one actually
comes from from facebook and says could
you be any more delusional you
constantly spew propaganda and claims
that are easily disprove easily proven
false
then you never retract you're a pathetic
joke i have to congratulate this person
um it seems almost like a legal
requirement that if you send right wing
hate mail
you mix up your and the contraction for
you are y o u apostrophe re
this person actually got the right
you're here and they really should be
commended for that now everything else
they say is of course untrue they don't
cite anything that i was wrong about or
correct me they're also wrong that we
never retract in fact when i'm made
aware
that we got something wrong on the show
i will usually open the following show
and actually just say hey i got
something wrong yesterday and here's
what it was i apologize here's what uh
here's what it is
um okay next one from chris chris says
vaccine hesitancy in other countries
david sir i've recently read there is
vaccine hesitancy in other parts of the
world i realize that in america
most of the hesitancy is politically
based what is your opinion of this
phenomenon in other countries love your
show listen daily paid subscriber keep
up the great work
it's different in different countries
we've talked about vaccine hesitancy for
example in france versus in italy
and in other countries as well in in
some places it is political
as influenced by what's going on in the
united states so there are other
countries where folks have been
convinced by the rantings of american
right-wingers about it's authoritarian
it's oppressive all of this different
stuff and they've just sort of gone with
that there's also a pretty sizable
anti-big pharma
sentiment in in some other countries
that drives vaccine hesitancy and you
know in the united states we talked
about this with nicolas christakis two
weeks ago
before the covet vaccines in the united
states you had anti-vaxx on the left and
you also had it on the right
the left-wing anti-vaxx tended to be
motivated by distrust of big pharma i
don't trust big corporations
the anti-vax on the right tended to be
dominated by i don't trust the
government meaning if a school requires
my kid to be vaccinated i don't trust
that or whatever the case may be and so
you had a kind of crossover of anti-vaxx
from left and right in the united states
covet anti-vaxx is overwhelmingly
right-wing there it's it still exists on
the left
uh jordan klepper recently did some
interesting interviews with some folks
in uh at the la area
and they don't seem particularly
right-wing they seem more of distrustful
of vaccines along the
sort of like reiki homeopathy herbs type
thing which is more more of a left-wing
thing and you see that more in other
countries as well you see that in italy
you see that in france as well so the
answer to what drives anti-vax in other
countries is it depends on which country
and there's a little bit of everything
floating around
a next email came from pp
who says hey david i was wondering if
you could shed some light on this new
fouchy bill gates email thread that alex
jones and glenn becker saying is a
smoking gun that covid was a product of
gain of function research and then
them along with moderna had the vaccine
created six months before the virus came
out
and released it on purpose
and all kind of wacky stuff yeah i can't
comment unfortunately i can't shed any
light into that
that sounds like five or six different
conspiracy theories
blended together into a smoothie of
sorts
and i have no idea how they all come
together i've never even heard of them
put together into one conspiracy like
that one thing i think uh is is
important to consider
is
if the conspiracy is so confusing
that you can't even really come up with
plausible motive linking all of these
groups together like as i've said many
times before
finding motive alone does not prove a
conspiracy theory but if you can't even
find
motive or understand it or even really
understand what the theory is be
skeptical of the people that are telling
you that this is the way that things are
austin rhoden
about trump's weird sniff
and says david i haven't heard you bring
this up yet but another one of trump's
big tells is that sniff thing he does
after almost every sentence very
annoying and a pretty good indicator
he's spinning another yarn keep it up
bud i i've never seen the trump sniffing
as a signal that he's lying
because he sniffs almost all the time
now you might say well yeah but david
he's lying almost all the time but even
when he says inconsequential things i
see the sniff more of like as a tick or
maybe something related to medication he
takes or something like that and it is
notable he'll say uh you know i got home
and melania said to me sir you were on
tv
and then there there's the sniff there
um for me it's less about lying it just
seems to be a verbal thing that trump
does maybe maybe related to medication
but it never seems specifically like a
lie signal the big lie signals i've
identified are he claims someone called
him sir
like when he the infamous story the one
that's the obvious lie when he said you
know when i came into office a general
came to me and said sir we have no
ammunition we're out of bullets from
obama
and i told him well let's buy more like
that story couldn't have happened that's
a lie the other one is he says and it's
really a shame you know he'll say
well
a hundred thousand dead people voted and
they took uh they took michigan and
pennsylvania and arizona from me and
it's really a shame it's really a shame
that's a sign that he's lying and then
the other one is and it should never
happen again or we can't let it happen
again they they took the election with
an insurrection on november 3rd and we
can't let it happen again he's lying
when he uses that one and also many many
others but the sniff one for me uh that
that's a different category
leslie wrote in with a non-political
question this is actually a really good
question leslie says hey david love the
show would appreciate your input
if a group of people go on vacation
together
would you split the cost of the vacation
rental per person
or per bedroom
i've always subscribed to per person but
have discovered recently a friend uses
the per bedroom calculation when divided
per bedroom the single friend pays more
for their room than the couple
in my mind all other parts of the rental
home and its amenities would be
considered equal so why not the bedrooms
in your opinion which is correct
you could really go either way with this
you know if when let's imagine not a
vacation rental but let's imagine an
apartment right because at a vacation
rental you don't usually pay for
electricity
water utilities etc if you're renting an
apartment and you've got a couple
sharing a room and then a single person
sharing a room it seems reasonable to me
that you would say okay
in terms of space
we have a room
and you have a room so that would be
split equally even though it's two
people versus one but you would adjust
for the fact that utilities are going to
be higher for the two people and how i
do that how you do that i don't know you
say well we will pay i guess you just
say if the utilities are paid separately
we'll pay two thirds of the utilities
but half of the rent that seems
reasonable mathematically on a vacation
i think i would take a totally different
approach quite frankly and it's who
proposes it and honestly who makes more
money uh you know there's a lot of
situations i've been in where it's sort
of like
if someone if someone is financially
better off and says i'm the one renting
i'm renting this house either way
come on and you know give me throw me a
hundred bucks or you know whatever the
case may be
that's often the way it actually goes
less than on a per person or per bedroom
basis but as a general thing on on a
vacation rental
i lean heavily on per bedroom
per bedroom let me know what you think
evan wrote in and says conservative
hypocrisy
about natural
immunity david sir i see many
conservatives and vaccine skeptics
espousing the use of monoclonal
antibodies to treat covid such as dennis
prager or your more recent segment on
joe rogan supporting it this seems very
counterintuitive to their baseless
theory that so-called natural immunity
is better than vaccine immunity
is it not hypocritical that they are so
against a vaccine that will strengthen
the immune system against covid but are
willing to take a different drug that
also strengthens your immune system
against covet i understand the drugs and
their effects are different but from
their perspective of so-called natural
immunity they are still unnatural
substances you're putting into your body
to fight off off the virus of course
yeah monoclonal antibodies listen when
they say they don't trust the vaccine
but they trust the antibodies the pfizer
vaccine is now fully approved whereas
the antibodies are only approved via
emergency use so it's a lower standard
number two when they say i don't trust
big pharma
the the monoclonal antibodies are also
made by big pharma and they are far more
profitable and i think about two
thousand dollars per treatment than you
know a fifteen to thirty dollar vaccine
so the money argument also doesn't make
sense and yes in a sense you were you
were generating immunity
not simply by fighting off the virus
but via the integration
of other antibodies that you didn't
create into your body so it is
absolutely hypocritical
along those lines as well very very good
point and
what's the answer the answer is they
don't actually care they're just against
the vaccine because all the arguments
they make against it fall apart when you
see that they're doing monoclonal
antibodies or other big pharma
treatments or things that are not
actually fda approved either
james wrote in and says congressman
nunes was on the evening edit on fox and
my job practically dropped they were
complaining about hunter biden making
money with china and now he shouldn't be
allowed to fly on air force one and he
was trading with the enemy these are the
same people that had no problem with the
kushners making hundreds of millions of
dollars while working in the white house
and ivanka being granted trademarks by
the chinese government
my advice on this hunter biden stuff is
do not even engage just just ignore it
like i don't i don't really know what
they're saying now about hunter i know
some right wingers write to me and say
david you should be talking about hunter
hunter has no involvement with the biden
administration and of course all of the
criticisms of hunter apply
well maybe not all but close to all of
the criticisms of hunter apply
certainly to jared and ivanka at minimum
um if not also to don jr and eric trump
they don't apply to baron i guess that's
that would be the exception and tiffany
everybody forgets about yeah just i
wouldn't even pay attention quite
frankly
uh zach from orlando has a crazy story
um and says
just wanted to share a story i overheard
while at the office yesterday for
context i work in orlando
and occasionally have to visit the
corporate office in tampa when i arrived
i overheard our coo and cfo complaining
about the traffic on i-4 and how it's
all part of biden's america you see
david according to these highly overpaid
executives ever since biden got into
office nobody wants to work since nobody
wants to work
there's less truck drivers on the road
that would be fewer since there's fewer
truck drivers on the road trucking
companies have to hire people with less
experience although i thought nobody
wanted to work and finally since there
are more inexperienced truck drivers on
the road there's more traffic
ah
because by virtue of being less
experienced they drive more slowly i
guess
makes sense right couldn't possibly have
anything to do with our crumbling
infrastructure poor public transit
options etc nope all biden's fault yeah
that's that's pretty full on i mean that
that's wackier
it's so specific
and it's sort of a problem how do i even
say it's an explanation in search of a
problem sort of i don't even know how to
say it fully uh but that's really wacky
and zach i'm really sorry that you're
working around that uh that that kind of
nonsense hopefully it's not like that
every day
uh thanks for all of your emails you can
send yours to info
davidpakman.com and we've got a great
bonus show planned for you today you can
sign up at joinpacman.com
and otherwise we'll be back with you on
monday
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors
blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an entire
nonfiction book in just 15 minutes you
can try it for free and get 25 percent
off a subscription by going to
blinkist.com
david pakman